all right Don Lemon
uh has been demoted essentially not
essentially I mean he's been we know
that um
at CNN they're kind of scrambling and
trying to figure out what's wrong with
their ratings I mean what's wrong with
the ratings is nobody wants to watch CNN
so
um they got we know they got rid of
Brian stelter they got rid of uh Chris
Cuomo a while ago and they're revamping
their Prime Time lineup they're taking
Don Lemon and they're kicking them down
to the morning show and they're demoting
them they're taking them out of prime
time putting them somewhere that's not
prime time but um this is kind of
embarrassing for him he uh
rather than just kind of going quietly
on his show last night he's defending
himself
and we just talked about the problem of
like getting defensive he's defending
himself against the claim that he was
demoted
and here's how that went
I was presented with an opportunity that
I can't pass up at this network and we
have a new boss who
um is a Morning Show impresario and he
wants a morning show that will kick off
the editorial direction of the network
every single day and I am honored that
he asked me to do it and for all of
those who are out there saying oh he
moved me and without my he asked me and
I said yes I could have said no this is
my show I have a contract for this show
I decided that I would take him up on
that and take this journey with him so
this is not someone moving me and by the
way this is not someone saying You must
move to the right Don Lemon and you must
not be so
um give so much of your perspective none
of that has happened all of that is
fodder for Twitter which is not real so
stop it I was not demoted none of that
this is an opportunity this is a
promotion this is this is
um an opportunity for me to create
something around me and I get to work
with two great ladies who you know Poppy
Harlow who I've known for more than a
decade I went to her wedding in Slovenia
I know her children I know her husband
and Caitlyn Collins same thing we've
been friends since Caitlin has been at
the networks
this I was not demoted I wasn't
here's something we haven't talked about
in a while let me ask you this what if
there was someone out there who kept a
log of every single thing you did every
minute of the day what have I told you
that's exactly what happens every time
you go online they're logging everything
logs all over the place your internet
provider is like ATT or Comcast they're
allowed to store logs of every website
you've ever visited and can legally sell
this data to anyone that's why I always
use expressvpn expressvpn reroutes your
internet connection through their secure
servers so your internet provider can't
see or log what you do online now many
of you might be wondering
well if I'm routing all my data through
a VPN doesn't that mean that the VPN can
see what I'm doing and log my data
instead ah very insightful you're right
to think that but many vpns in fact do
claim to have a no logs policy but
they've been caught logging customer
activity anyway
expressvpn is different that's why
they're the only VPN I trust because
they use trusted server technology this
makes it impossible for their VPN
servers to store any data including logs
of any expressvpn customer and you don't
have to take my or expressvpn's word for
it expressvpn is so confident in their
no logs claim that they have had one of
the biggest Assurance firms audit their
technology so stop letting people keep
logs of what you do online visit
expressvpn.com Matt walshow right now
and find out how you can get three
months free
uh I love the phrase there I I I decided
to take this journey with him
so your boss calls you in and says uh
yeah we're kicking you down a few
notches here you're not you're not
performing well
you know we're gonna give you a pay cut
a demotion
okay I'll take this journey with you
let's go hand in hand on this journey
um first of all nobody volunteers for to
do the morning show especially not from
Prime Time like you're gonna you really
you want to get up at 3 30 in the
morning
and do and do a show it's what you
really want instead of being in prime
time I doubt it
but he also noticed he his his uh near
admission of bias not that we need him
to admit it we already know but he
almost admits it
he says um
he says oh no it's it's it they didn't
come to me and say move to the right
stop being
and then he stops himself uh you know
stop giving my perspective so he almost
said they didn't tell me move to the
right stop being so liberal
and then he stopped himself
again not that we needed his admission
but even so well before you go uh hit
the Subscribe button and ring the bell
and while you're at it if you want to go
watch or listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe you can also
catch my show on Spotify Apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now I demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated